البحث عن الأحباء المفقودين الذي
أضعه في رقم هوية أختي الصغرى ،
عبد الله هو ناشط في مجال حقوق الإنسان
وأويغور من منطقة شينجيانغ الصينية
من المنفى في النرويج ، وهو يبحث لأول
مرة في ملف الشرطة الصينية
من عام 2017 بشأن أخته ساجدة.
حقًا بالتفصيل لم يتحدث
معها منذ سنوات اعتقلت
6 سبتمبر / أيلول وأرسلت إلى معسكر التعليم
مكثت هناك لمدة شهر تقريبًا ثم أرسلتها
إلى مركز الاحتجاز وحكم عليها بالسجن لمدة
11 عامًا
ينص ملف الشرطة الصينية على أن
ساجدة أيوب ذات وجهين  أو يبدو أن
الشرطة الرسمية الحكومية الخائنة قد
أبلغت عن مدرس الجغرافيا بالمدرسة الثانوية
بسبب صلاته بأخيها ،
وهو ناقد صريح مرة واحدة سجنته
الحكومة الصينية ،
أخبرتني الوثيقة الحكومية نعم ، إنها
مرتبطة بك وأنه
خطأك
أنت.  الوصول المبكر إلى
محرك البحث الجديد هذا ، إنه مرتبط بعشرات
الآلاف من الملفات التي تم اختراقها من
أجهزة الكمبيوتر التابعة للشرطة في شينجيانغ ، هناك 830
ألف شخص مختلف في هذه الملفات ،
ومن الواضح من الملفات أن عشرات
الآلاف منهم محتجزون من قبل Adrian
zens a  أصدر باحث مع ضحايا
مؤسسة Communism Memorial Foundation لأول مرة
بعض ملفات الشرطة التي تم اختراقها
في العام الماضي ، ولم تنكر الحكومة الصينية
صحتها ، لكن
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية انتقدت تحليله
للبيانات ووصفها بأنها معلومات مضللة ،
وتنفي بكين أنها ارتكبت انتهاكات لحقوق الإنسان
أثناء احتجازها حتى  2 مليون من
الأويغور العرقيين وغيرهم من الأقليات في
معسكرات إعادة التعليم في شينجيانغ ، وهي
حملة قمع جماعي
تدعي الحكومة الأمريكية أنها ترقى إلى الإبادة الجماعية ،
أطلق زينز محرك البحث على أمل
أن يزود الأويغور في الشتات
بمعلومات عن أفراد الأسرة في
الوطن في شينجيانغ ، الثقب الأسود  هو
الشيء الأكثر رعبا وأعتقد أن هذا
جزء من سبب قيام الدولة الصينية بإنشاء
هذا الثقب الأسود ، إنه الشيء الأكثر رعبا
الذي يمكن القيام به حتى أنك لا
تعرف حتى أن مصير أحد أفراد أسرته ليس
حياة أو ميتة ماما جون
يتذكر جمعة في 12 يونيو (حزيران) 2006 آخر مرة
رأى فيها عائلته ، أتذكر ذلك اليوم الذي كنت
أعبر فيه حاجز التفتيش بالمطار وكانوا
يلوحون ورأيتهم صورتهم
لا تزال في ذهني ، فأنت تعلم أن الصورة
تأتي إلي أحيانًا ،
لذا فهذه هي الأخيرة.  في الوقت الذي رأيت فيه
إخوتي ،
أصبح الآن صحفيًا يعمل في
خدمة اللغة الأويغورية المجانية الإذاعية في آسيا في
واشنطن العاصمة والتي تصنفها بكين على أنها
منظمة دعاية مناهضة للصين
غير قادرة على العودة إلى ديارها خوفًا من الاعتقال
ولا ترغب حتى في الاتصال بأقاربه
خوفًا من أن يكونوا كذلك.  نعاقب ، دعنا
نرى أنني سأفتش أحد إخوتي
حتى الآن يمكنه فقط إلقاء نظرة على ملفات الشرطة الخاصة بهم ، هل
أكدت الملفات
احتجاز أي من أحبائك ، نعم ،
احتجاز إخوتي الثلاثة ، نعم ،
ثم عثرت على أحد
صور الأخ في ذلك أه في ذلك الملف صورة
mugshot لأخيه الأصغر عيسى
جون في الحجز كيف يبدو
شكله آه لقد فقد روحه
يمنحك شعورًا بالذنب كما تعلمون
لأنهم مرتبطون بذلك.
أنت وهم مضطهدون ، فليس من
السهل حقًا استيعاب
صورة جمعة وإخوته في
أوقات أكثر سعادة ، أتمنى أن أعود إلى
هذه اللحظة ، أنت تعلم أنني أتمنى أن
أعود إلى هذه اللحظة
اليوم.  ترك تجميع ما
حدث لعائلته من خلال
ملفات الشرطة الصينية ومستوى
التفاصيل حتى على الأشخاص الذين لم يتم
اتهامهم قط بارتكاب جرائم تقشعر لها الأبدان عينات
الحمض النووي عينات
الصوت
صور الملف الشخصي مسح قزحية لذلك هذه هي
المعلومات البيومترية التي جمعوها
عن والدتي عندما  تنظر إليه حتى
ترى هذا المثال المثالي
لدولة مراقبة كاملة
نصف العالم بعيدًا في أديلايد أستراليا ،
عثرت مرحبا يعقوب سالاي للتو على
ملف شرطة لابن أخيها البالغ من العمر 17 عامًا ، وهو أمر
مجنون وهذا أمر فظيع لا
لم أكن أتوقع ذلك  ينص الملف على أنه
في عام 2017 عندما كان الصبي يبلغ من العمر 12 عامًا فقط ،
وصفته الشرطة بالفئة الثانية بأنه
متواطئ مشبوه للغاية في
قضية تتعلق بالأمن العام أو الإرهاب ، وهذا
ليس كل شيء هنا ، فهذه ابنة أخي
لديها ملف شرطة
بأي حال من الأحوال يدعي الملف أنه من خلال
سافرت ابنة أخت مرحبا البالغة من العمر 15 عامًا على
نطاق واسع شيئًا ما تنكره خالتها
أرتيليا أفغانستان أذربيجان دبي مصر
باكستان لا توجد طريقة لأن الأمر الرئيسي يعني أنهم
يقولون إنها كانت في هذا البلد
حتى الآن لم يتم احتجاز أي من الطفلين
ولكن صالح قلق على مستقبلهما.
الأم مايلا كانت أختها
محتجزة بالفعل وخرجت منها منذ سنوات
متهمة بتمويل الإرهاب
لتحويلها أموالاً إلى والديها في أستراليا
للمساعدة في شراء منزل إذا كان بإمكانك إخبارهم
بشيء ما تود
إخبارهم به ، أنا آسف جدًا لما يحدث  لهم وأنا
آسف جدًا لما
يحدث لأمهم ، أختي ،
أنا آسف لأنني لا أستطيع مساعدتهم
لأنهم يستحقون أفضل بكثير من هذا ، فهم
أبرياء لأن أكثر من 800000
ملف تعريف للشرطة لا تقدم سوى
لقطة جزئية للنطاق الأوسع.  نظام
المراقبة والقمع في شينجيانغ
لا يخففون من
ذنب الناجي الذي يتقاسمه العديد من الأقارب الذين يعيشون
في الخارج يائسين لمعرفة أي شيء عن
أحبائهم في الصين.
إيفان واتسون سي إن إن هونغ كونغ